Nick Cassidy said pop should I continue
to DCA into Bitcoin in stocks or build a
cash position this is a very interesting
question the first answer is I don't
give Financial advice every single
person your individual situation is
going to dictate uh what you should do
so things to consider one how much cash
do you currently have two what's your
current portfolio look like three is
what are you optimizing for and when
what are you optimizing for is going to
really depend on how old you are what
your current employment situation is
what are your expenses all that type of
stuff and then the last thing I think is
like what do you want or what makes you
happy in life so you take those four
things into consideration what my guess
is is uh in an overarching way what many
people are going to end up with is
you're going to need some sort of cash
position that can last uh in case
something bad happens it's all fun and
games and people like all damn is real
bound people getting fired until you get
fired and then you're like [ __ ] I don't
have any income what am I going to do so
my guess is that people are going to try
to get at first to one month of of uh
kind of monthly expenses sitting in the
bank then they're gonna try to get to
three months maybe even six months it's
a big number but there's a lot of people
who try to get to that so cash position
think of that as your rainy day fund God
forbid something goes wrong you know
that I'm good for three to six months
then what people are gonna start to say
is okay that's my defensive position I
got cash sitting on the sidelines that I
know that I'm good regardless of what
happens work etc my offensive mentality
or my offensive Playbook I got to start
thinking about how am I going to deploy
my excess cash so I use these e numbers
let's just say that I needed a hundred
dollars for my rainy day fund takes me a
month or two okay I save up save up bam
I got I already had some Cash Plus extra
I'm good now let's just say that gives
me three months of my rainy day I put it
there I don't touch it I don't care how
high inflation is I don't care because I
know that that's gonna make sure I'm
good
on offense what a lot of people will do
is they'll sit there like oh it stuff's
going lower it's going lower it's going
lower I'm gonna wait to buy it lower I'm
gonna wait to buy it lower maybe or
maybe this is the bottom maybe I don't
know I'm not trying to time markets all
I know is that when prices go up in any
asset class whether that would be uh
real estate Commodities stocks Bitcoin
crypto whatever
dollar cost average in dollar cost
average and dollar cost average in but
when prices fall I still think of it as
dollar cost average and dollar cost
average in I just may do it on an
accelerated timeline so an example of
that would be okay if I was going to
make a purchase of Bitcoin right I'm
talking about myself personally again
not Financial advice if I was going to
make purchases of Bitcoin every other
week now maybe what I'll do is I'll do
it every week or maybe I'll do it every
couple of days and the thought process
here is like use Bitcoin as the asset 40
000 was at the bottom well obviously not
now we're down at 35 36 000. is that the
bottom I don't know maybe it goes to 30
maybe it doesn't I don't know but
instead what I'm going to try to do is
anywhere that is lower than where I was
buying a couple of months ago probably a
pretty good decision and so ultimately
what they're going to end up doing is
people are going to start to uh just
dollar cost average into these assets so
I think that's really the way that most
people try to uh to do this and so uh
Andy uh Juan I think I said uh he said
opinion trying to catch a falling knife
first dcing DCA on the way down I think
is another way to think about this as
well is you can go ahead and as your
dollar cost averaging if let's say for
example uh Bitcoin goes to some really
really low number right a thousand
dollars let's use a super extreme no way
that's going to happen but let's just
say that that occurred if you were
started buying at thirty five thousand
dollars and you were dollar cost
averaging on your way down you basically
were quote unquote catching a falling
knife but
at the same time if your dollar costs
averaging into an asset and it ends up
bottoming at 35 000 then you are
quotable buying the bottom the problem
is that nobody has a crystal ball you
can't see in the future so I tend to
think that if you have conviction in any
asset commodity real estate stocks
crypto whatever
and it has volatility to it
you're best off simply just dollar cost
averaging now that requires that when
you get the cast position right so that
you're able to actually weather any sort
of financial hardship in your personal
life the second thing is that you have
the excess cash flow on top of the rainy
day fund to be able to invest and then
the third thing is you got a long time
Horizon so what you can't do is if
you're somebody who's got high leverage
right let's say that you had some
Bitcoin you levered it up you bought
more Bitcoin you did all the stuff now
all of a sudden it's a little scary
because you may become a forced seller
so a lot of times what ends up occurring
and this is true of all asset classes I
talked to every single one of the best
investors in the world for the most part
what ends up being a Telltale uh kind of
story or or a common story is that
investors when they're young and when
they're first starting out it's all
about how high can it go how rich can I
get how much money can I make in this
trade in this investment or in this
strategy
as they build wealth it becomes less
about how much can I make and it becomes
much more about how can I be sure that
I'm durable through good times and bad
times now they have the benefit of
they've got a cash position to be able
to uh think that way
um or an Investment Portfolio to think
that way but the second thing that's
really important is that they also as
they build their wealth they get
experience and so you see right now
there's a lot of venture capitalists
there's a lot of stock uh Market
investors Etc all talking on Twitter uh
about hey the 2008 financial crisis or
the 2001 Tech uh bust Etc
sure
but there's a lot of folks who are
investors right now who never lived
through that stuff they didn't have
investment portfolios in 2008 or 2001
2000 whatever so when you start to see
that what you got to ask yourself is
what is the experience I'm going to get
right now and a lot of people are going
to learn that you have to be durable and
so you can still go for the super
asymmetric investment but you got to
have that durability without that
durability there ends up being a pretty
big problem